we are continuing to follow this
amazingly explosive story about Donald
Trump and his tax returns and the
backstory has been 40 years candidates
have released their tax returns for the
public to take a look at Donald Trump
has said he would not be doing this
there have been a number of polls done
that confirmed there is huge interest in
seeing Donald Trump's tax returns and
we've speculated and so has Hillary
Clinton and so have many others about
what they might reveal do they reveal
would they reveal that Donald Trump is
not as wealthy as he says he is would
they reveal that he has not been paying
taxes would they reveal that he has more
connections with Russia than he has
admitted would they reveal that maybe he
hasn't donated to charity to the degree
he says he has well we have now learned
about Donald Trump's 1995 tax return
I'll tell you exactly how the New York
Times got it in a second this is the
first shoe to drop in what is very
clearly bombshell information that is
out there with every new bit of
information that we get it becomes more
and more clear that there is a lot going
on with Donald Trump's taxes the New
York Times has obtained some older
Donald Trump tax records and they show
that in 1995 Donald Trump declared a
nine hundred and sixteen million dollar
loss on his income tax return this tax
deduction is so huge that it could have
allowed Donald Trump to legally avoid
paying any federal income taxes for up
to 18 years you'll remember when Hillary
Clinton mentioned during that first
debate a week ago that it's not clear
Donald Trump has even paid tax as many
years Donald Trump responded by saying
that makes me smart and indeed the 1995
tax return at least would set Trump up
to be able to avoid paying significant
levels of federal income taxes now how
did the New York Times get these
documents the documents were mailed last
month to Zeus
Suzanne Craig who's a reporter at The
New York Times who has written in the
past about Donald Trump's finances the
documents were the first page
of a New York State resident income tax
return the first page of a New Jersey
non-resident tax return and the first
page of a Connecticut non-resident
return each page contained the social
security number of both Donald Trump and
his then wife Marla maples now the three
documents showed up at the New York
Times by mail with a postmark indicating
that they were sent from within New York
City the return address claimed that the
documents came from Trump Tower now of
course you can write any return address
and then just drop it in a New York City
mailbox and it will be postmarked in New
York City and it will have whatever
return address you wrote on it let's
keep that in mind the New York Times
took these documents and presented them
to Jack Mitnick who's a lawyer and
certified public accountant who actually
handled Donald Trump's tax returns for
more than 30 years until 1996 mr.
Mitnick was listed on this New Jersey
tax form as the preparer he's now
semi-retired and living in Florida said
he no longer has access to Donald
Trump's tax returns but that indeed the
documents appear to be authentic parts
of Donald Trump's tax returns and that
the signature purportedly on these
documents is indeed his okay so let's
take a look at a couple things here
first and foremost I want to show you
the bit of Donald Trump's tax returns
where we see a nine hundred and fifteen
point seven million dollar negative
adjusted gross income okay we can't say
for sure the implications of this loss
on future years because we don't have
Donald Trump's tax returns for future
years but we do know that a loss this
big in 1995 would have been large enough
to wipe out 50 million dollars per year
of taxable income over the following 18
years
Donald Trump has declined to comment on
the documents instead the campaign put
out a statement that it doesn't chow
nor confirmed the 916 million dollar
loss let's take a look at this statement
from Donald Trump that I will show you
from the Trump campaign mr. Trump is a
highly skilled businessman who has a
fiduciary responsibility to his business
his family and his employees to pay no
more tax than legally required that
being said mr. Trump has paid hundreds
of millions of dollars in property taxes
sales and excise taxes real estate taxes
city taxes state taxes employee taxes
and federal taxes mr. Trump knows the
tax code far better than anyone who has
ever run for president and he is the
only one that knows how to fix it this
is what people say when they are accused
of not paying income tax they said hey
hey hey
I play pay plenty of taxes there's sales
taxes and excise taxes this is the most
common way that someone who is accused
of not paying income taxes responds when
it is true that they have not paid
income taxes now remember Mitt Romney
Mitt Romney in 2012 having a 13%
effective tax rate was considered a
bombshell how does this rich guy Mitt
Romney get away with paying only 13%
effective tax rate it appears that
Donald Trump may have paid zero for many
many years remember and I'll put this
tweet up on the screen for you remember
when Donald Trump complained that
President Obama paid only 20% taxes on
his 790 thousand dollar income President
Obama paying a much higher rate at least
in some years than Donald Trump on a
fraction of Donald Trump's income at
least in some years the biggest thing
for me here is the insanity that Donald
Trump has in some way vindicated Mitt
Romney Mitt Romney was sort of awkward
at times he had a difficult time
connecting with voters he was a rich guy
who didn't understand a lot of the basic
day-to-day things that normal people
deal with but he seems like a reasonable
guy
who paid his taxes even though it was
only 13% compared
to Donald Trump also with Mitt Romney
you could actually check his business
record and see that he was a good
businessman he was legitimately
successful in business I I don't agree
with the way that Mitt Romney took
advantage of taking businesses apart and
hurting many employees I don't agree
with the model personally on a moral
level but it was verifiable we of course
have no reason to believe that good
business people make good presidents and
that remains with both Trump and Mitt
Romney but Mitt Romney's narrative was
at least verifiable and true this is a
potential disaster for Donald Trump on
many levels Hillary Clinton appears to
have been right that's number one
Donald Trump every indication is he's
hiding something terrible in his tax
returns
number two Donald Trump's businessman
credentials are also called into
question losing a billion dollars in a
year could be some kind of tax strategy
right he might have paid in a billion
dollars of his personal wealth into his
businesses allowing him to show a
billion dollar loss and then in
subsequent years being able to use that
loss to offset taxes on future income
that's one possibility and it would be
legal but incredibly manipulative and
really I would argue completely
unpatriotic or it could be that he's not
as good of a businessman as he claims
and this billion dollar loss in a year
was the result of bad business decisions
either case is not particularly good for
Donald Trump the broader analysis is
everyday this is in the the news it is
not good for Donald Trump and my
prediction is we will be hearing more
about this there will be more
information surfacing I was recently
sent and I've been wearing a really cool
watch from movement watches also known
as MVM tea and I absolutely love this
watch a lot of people have been asking
me about it movement watches is
interesting because they started
similarly to how the david pakman show
started which was it was two broke
college kids who wanted to wear stylish
watches but couldn't afford them so they
started their own watch company they
used crowdfunding to build their
business in the same way that we at the
David Pakman show
have used crowdfunding to build the show
the great thing about movement watches
is they start at just $95 these are
watches that for this level of quality
and design you're talking about four to
five hundred dollars at department
stores and movement figured out that by
selling online you can cut out a lot of
the middle people and the retail markup
and offer the best possible prices so
you can actually get 15% off today with
free shipping and free returns by going
to mV MT watches dot-com / Pakman that's
PA que ma n I love this watch I love the
clean design been getting a ton of
compliments and the greatest part is I
haven't been late to a single meeting go
to MV MT watches dot-com / Pakman PA que
ma n